merci brigitte bien tout d'abord je
voudrais dire que ce sentiment
d'insécurité
contrairement à ce que l'on peut penser
ne n'est pas des grandes des lits des
grands crimes mais il n'est de tous et
ses troubles à la tranquillité publique
que vous subissez dans votre quotidien
des jeunes qui se regroupent qui en
comportement agressif qui s'empare du
domaine public qui taguent les murs tout
ceci contribue à ces espèces de malaise
et surtout ce qui est à noter c'est que
tous ces petits délits ne sont plus
poursuivis parce que les parcs et très
franchement ont d'autres choses à faire
alors il n'est une espèce de double
frustration
tout d'abord il ya le fait qu'il ait pas
de réponse encourage de certains mineurs
a continué en clair la société ne leur
donne plus le moindre signal d'arrêt et
d'autre part bien évidemment on peut le
comprendre un sentiment de frustration
des gens qui se sentent abandonnés
puisqu'il n'y a pas de réponse à tous
ces petits délits alors tout à l'heure
quand brice hortefeux disait que la
prévention était l'apanage de la gauche
non le bavardage c'est l'apanage de la
gauche parce qu'en termes de prévention
ils n'ont jamais rien fait si ce n'est
la culture du colloque ou d'ailleurs je
vois beaucoup de professionnels de la
prévention mais jamais vu d'ailleurs un
délinquant
eh bien c'était notre gloire je dirais
qu'en mars 2007 nous ayons fait nous une
loi pour donner plus de pouvoir au maire
pour pouvoir agir en termes de
prévention et je parle devant caroline
pozmentier parce que nous avons créé à
l'époque un outil qui s'appelait la
cellule de citoyenneté et de
tranquillité publique
c'est très simple autour du maire on met
le chef d'établissement
autour du maire on met des travailleurs
sociaux on met les forces de police les
forces de gendarmerie et cette espèce de
collégialité aide le maire à prendre des
décisions décision pour
c'est un processus j'ai un jeune je
prends des exemples un gamin qui va plus
au collège qui se retrouvent sur le wan
public est en situation de danger et
bien le maire avec le chef
d'établissement réuni convoque les
familles ermotti d'un petit peu les
parents pour les inscrire leurs enfants
dans un processus de pédagogie
deuxième exemple un jeune qui profère
des injures solo république est bien le
maire peut faire un rappel à l'ordre en
grande solennité et c'est souvent le
maire qui est le seul qui peut à nouveau
recréer un contacter les familles
troisième point le maire peut donner ce
qu'on appelle des réparations un jeune
qui a tagué un mur mais c'est la bonne
pédagogie que de condamner jusqu'à faire
15 heures de travail non rémunéré pour
réparer pour repeindre le mur parce que
la population voit qui est une réponse
et puis pour les jeunes c'est un
caractère d'exemplarité sauf que sauf
que chaque fois qu'il faut donner une
sanction
le parquet ne suit pas et que vaut la
prévention s'il n'y a pas de sanction au
bout donc voilà quelques réflexions que
je vous proposes tu as dit brigitte htc
parue dans le jdd
je crois que c'est un travail de longue
haleine et sur lequel il faut être très
volontaire et déterminé je pense bruno
qui a fait allusion au fait que les
forces que les forces de l'ordre
recentrent sur leur coeur de métier
moi je propose une chose très simple
bruno laissons le régalien à la police
gendarmerie et les ceusses qui est ce
que j'appelle la sécurité publique et
laissons au maire et à la police
municipale tout ce qui la tranquillité
publique de façon très très clair on
sépare ces deux notions
ça veut dire combien une coda sécurité
publique combien cours de la santé
combien code environnement pourquoi ne
ferions nous pas un code de la
tranquillité publique et c'est le maire
qui en serait responsable
avec sa police municipale d'autre part
je sais que cette idée dérange parfois
mais sont classés dans les délits
les crimes le fait de barbouiller murs
avec des tags le maire donc ne peut pas
agir
eh bien il s'agit de ramener tous ces
petits délits dans le champ du
contraventionnelle dans la compétence du
maire pour que le maire puisse dire un
jeune sans passer par le procureur tu a
bousillé un mur bien tu va repeindre
d'ailleurs les bombes vont être
supprimés vont être confisquée pour pour
qu'un maire puisse dire par exemple bien
tel jeunes ce regroupement de jeunes se
fait de vendre tel collège nous allons
demander à ce que hay et l'interdiction
de fréquenter l'endroit
donc il s'agit de donner aux maires un
vrai pouvoir de sanction et d'élargir
les réponses possibles
que ce soit des réponses pécuniaire ce
soit des réponses des sanctions plus
sévères avec du travail non rémunéré
parce que je regrette faire travailler
un jeune à la mairie pour réparer les
héros les arroseurs qu'il a bousillé
c'est de la bonne pédagogie ou de même
par exemple interdira aux jeunes de
fréquenter tel endroit
donc ça permettrait aux maires d'être au
coeur de l'action
là où actuellement plus personne plus
personne n'est présent
alors j'ai pas être trop long il est
évident ça peut fonctionner que si les
prérogatives de la police municipale
sont aussi augmenté vous savez qu'un
policier municipal ne peux même pas vous
demander votre identité
alors que la caissière du supermarché
vous le demande qui est quand même une
aberration pour qu'un policier municipal
demande vos papiers
il faut qu'il appelle les forces de
l'ordre police ou gendarmerie qui doit
venir à eux demander leurs papiers
donc c'est du temps perdu cher bruno et
c'est un manque d'efficacité au sida
police d'une véritable police de
proximité
donc je demande à aussi à ce que on
améliore on augmente la les prérogatives
de police municipale vous savez qu'un
policier municipal peut même pas avoir
accès de façon systématique au fichier
des plaques minéralogiques
donc à partir du moment où on leur
donnera des moyens bien supérieurs eh
bien je pense ça soulagera les forces
régaliennes et ça nous permettra aussi
d'être beaucoup plus efficace dans ses
réponses au quotidien voilà j'avais dit
que je serais pas trop long chez
brigitte je vais conclure mon propos en
disant seulement si ces policiers
municipaux et
son nom sonne demandeur doit avoir plus
de prérogatives
je propose aussi et le demande qu'ils
aient une formation bien supérieure à
celle qui est actuellement pour les
détails techniques passent par le cnfpt
je pense qu'il faut une véritable école
de formation police municipale et bien
mr avec des pouvoirs étendus assumer une
police municipale efficace là ce sera ma
conclusion ma chère brigitte la
prévention délinquance ne sera pas que
tu bavardage ce sera une réponse à
toutes ces incivilités qui gâchent la
vie de nos concitoyens au quotidien
voilà